the gyro can experience did you have any
involvement is barely related but did
you have any involvement no anybody that
had any involvement with those Mormon
cults that are down there
yes I do know people that in the horrors
region that some of the Mitt Romney's
family members in that region area yeah
I knew some federal I know some Federal
Police guys and military guys that were
curious about the amount of firearms
that these guys have because they had
some they basically fought the cartels
off how crazy is that well it's you know
it's pretty it's pretty interesting
being there and finding a white guy that
speaks amazing English and it was porn
in Mexico and he had there are Mormons
they're Mormons and they they have to
get like a visa to travel to us but here
people don't know that like Mitt
Romney's dad the reason why Mitt
Romney's dad never ran for president cuz
he was born in Mexico yeah yeah yeah I
mean there's a lot there's a lot of
white Mexicans which is another win
thing that people don't help or Canelo
Louie CK yeah Louie CK Mexico Canelo
yeah
anybody that's of Irish ancestry if you
go into a bar in Mexico some bars in
Mexico you can probably get some free
drinks if you tell me where Irish
because the Irish betrayed the Americans
in the last Mexico American War and a
lot of them stayed down there and
married some of the locals Irish last
name on one quarter that's how you got a
problem right yeah the that the the the
the the Mormon community in that area
basically a few of their members got
abducted yeah and the cartels were you
know wanted to do more against them and
these guys apparently got some
high-powered long-range rifles and they
were shooting at these people from afar
and they set up this whole security
apparatus around their town and the
Mexican government basically looked the
other way and kind of said you know
that's why and just don't you know don't
be get too crazy with it
yeah there was some sort of interaction
as far as uh them trying to appease
things with them you know because
realistically the town that they're that
they made out there as a paradise I mean
amongst other towns in that area it's a
beautiful place really the beautiful
plates very organized what is it called
this hit Jamie this is a Mormon little
town pack so what kind of military did
they have that protects this town like
if they've they've made their own
military so I actually got to do a few
reconnaissance things there just this
this is passing by and what I saw that
they had were a bunch of basically
machine-gun nest on some of the hilltops
and they lit the the limited the amount
of access points to that little town so
they had the bare basically there what
happened when the people got abducted I
think one of them got killed and then
you know they wanted to kill other
people and it was this whole thing they
went to the government for help and they
didn't say anything so somehow they you
know procured firearms down there so
they start defending their own what a
strange story that is because they left
the United States when polygamy was
illegal yes when they started making
polygamy illegal in Utah they went well
we'll just go to Mexico because back
when they did it there wasn't even cars
so it was like no big deal to live in
Mexico like you're riding a [ __ ]
horse no matter where you are yeah no
didn't no difference no and they said
we'll go over here but it is a nice I
mean again
it's a weird of American like town in
the middle of Juarez how many people go
Ayla it's probably the thousands tens of
thousands maybe Wow
yeah all Mormons all Mormons and a lot
of Mexican converts now so really yeah
there's a lot of Mexican converts down
there as well and are there more than
one family more than one of these towns
I think so yeah yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of family names or in that
region there are kind of famous
you know why one of the Barons are one
of those but it's only this one town
it's it's one upset there's there's a
few out there there's a few out there's
a few Mormon communities out there Wow
it's all the same sort of deal armed to
the tits
the discretely armed you know I don't
know if it's it's open as it was but
it's it would be back then when it was
really rowdy they were they were openly
doing you know things to keep people
from not coming to their town and
they're full-on Mexican citizens yes Wow
but they're but they speak English in
their wine so it's they don't speak
Spanish some of them do but they don't
need to because they live in this
community they don't go out of it a lot
so you know it's a wait it's a weird
place that's [ __ ] really weird yeah
[Applause]